on friday 11 june at
half past nine
this door will open and a
conference will start in which we want to talk
about the future of the netherlands but more
in particular the future of
western society
what's next for the west superman
nothing better than we start  with an
opening scale
and then we have two debates in
the first debate we are going to focus
mainly on european history and
then the question is
that ideal of en beethoven and beethoven
as a hero of society
because he was that until the first
world war why  were you doing
that why isn't it that anymore
and what did it actually mean where
did that stand for
inside and yes nice because it
I am I
mine are not reworked
yes all people brother the natural live
in harmony
would you like me to know about me
psychologist at not and all people
will one day be brothers often because of
we no longer believe in that why is that
really something we think of okay  we
've had it didn't work
it didn't prevent a first world
war it didn't prevent a second
world war completely it didn't come with an
outfit and has all that
misery we had afterwards we
don't prevent war under a beam
what else can we do with that then have
a  internet so and
beethoven himself is played of these his
last
piano sonatas opens inconvenient
when we sit listening i
actually want to know what
we hear then i'll do it one more goal but
to a goal
nice tune to listen to what we
actually do  can whistle along
or does it somehow have
a deeper meaning know more that it was more
for beethoven it is beautiful
music and then comes closed button and
that final debate is about the question what
is the future for a safe
search receiver real world  yes
I'm a bit afraid of that can vk with the
help of the actual
sep the dark feature we there
I sit one in which you see sang and
beforea  l with the climate
we are the future so i have
confidence in ourselves when growing up
a good job
nice children within mother
the generation that is now 20 here in this
country will have to do with considerably less
than the past generations of the
hard war for the  simple reason
that he can never compete with the
china knees
how do we deal with the social
tensions that it causes so and you see
it happening american the country is
divided to the bone over something quite
essential namely health
care half of the americans  ca
n't imagine that they
would contribute to the
goal of basic
health care for their fellow americans
america is no longer the super power
that comes from the east but what does
it have to offer us and what are
your ideas soon that  central come
to steep or one of the speakers in the
last bath is a very young swedish
viruses about but he is
leading a world of the tr  anshumanist what to believe
transhumanist er
the future belongs to biotechnology
biotechnology we build in chip everything will be
fine
what said at a certain moment the heroes
what are the most important icons at a certain moment
where do
people identify with and help the
show hide
snowboarder  maxima here is so weighted so
cozy isn't it
my hero is frits bolkestein bensberg
because i myself
the blanks my hero are my parents
god if he can everyone be a hero
who would still be who are the wonders us
for our society
and what does super my us
which indeed arose in 1938 in the
time of crisis when